das für ein gefühl als sie die fünf
prozent prognose gehört haben naja
natürlich sind wir enttäuscht es ist ein
schwerer einfach für die linke ist so
lange für uns ein harter weckruf dass
wir jetzt über die um die fünf prozent
kämpfen was ist klar und das ist
natürlich auch für uns einen einen
wirklich ein starkes ein starker weckruf
darüber dass wir gucken müssen woran es
denn jetzt gelegen hat ist es klar dass
wir als partei zusammenstehen müssen
denn eins ist auch klar wir wollen diese
gesellschaft verändern wir wollen eine
soziale alternative darstellen wir
wollen eine ökologische und auch eine
antirassistische alternative darstellen
und offenbar hätten wir uns in der
vergangenheit die eine oder andere
diskussion geschenkt aber das ist eine
sache die müssen wir in ruhe und
solidarisch gemeinsam diskutieren die
eigene diskussion geschenk das spiel
stimmen sie auf die vielstimmigkeit
innerhalb der linken an oder dass man
nicht ein fokus gewählt hat und dass man
das gelassen dann auch nicht den fehler
der wählerinnen vermitteln konnte was
man wirklich möchte oder ja sicher ist
es so dass wir eben gucken müssen wie
wir in der vergangenheit als performance
die wir darauf waren und da gab es
bestimmt sehr viel luft nach oben die
vielstimmigkeit haben sie angesprochen
da müssen wir natürlich raus wir müssen
klarmachen wofür die linke steht das
haben wir im wahlkampf ja auch getan
trotzdem wahlkämpfe sind natürlich das
eine die wahlkämpfe werden aber in den
jahren davor entschieden und das ist hat
der linken jetzt offenbar auch geschadet
stichwort vergangenheit die vergangenen
landtagswahlen zuletzt sachsen anhalt
schlager hab's schon eklatante verlust
zu brandenburg sachsen rheinland pfalz
baden würden dann haben sie versucht
hereinzukommen das heißt sie hatten ja
eigentlich genug potenzial jetzt in den
vergangenen jahren zu gucken wie
schaffen wir es dass wir die 9,2 prozent
der vergangenen bundestagswahlen
konzerns fast halbiert da schaut sie wir
sind eine partei in massiven umbruch wir
sind eine partei die etwa ein fünftel
ihrer mitgliedschaft in den letzten
zweieinhalb jahren hinzu aber auch
verloren hat jedes fünfte mitglied bei
uns ist neu in den letzten zweieinhalb
jahren und klar ist auch dass wir in
diesen jahren natürlich auch
mitgliederverluste insbesondere im osten
haben hinnehmen müssen das ist teil von
fehlen der verankerung
die wir dort jetzt auch in den
wahlergebnissen spüren das ist richtig
aber uns bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig
wir brauchen da eine veränderung wir
brauchen da einen schritt nach vorne den
haben wir in den letzten jahren als
partei auch gegangen und da müssen wir
jetzt natürlich konsequent bleiben und
da müssen wir auch klar machen wofür wir
als linke sozial ökologisch
antirassistisch stehen dann auch vom
gefühl sie hatten jetzt zuletzt sie den
wochen rot-rot-grün da war immer wieder
da hatte man das gefühl man kann zum
ersten mal mitregieren
jetzt sieht er momentan nach der ersten
prognose noch so aus dass das nicht so
ist wie enttäuscht sind sie naja
natürlich bedeutet das ein rückschlag
für eine reform option weil logisch ist
doch rot grün hat keine mehrheit das hat
es auch wieder gezeigt und nur mit der
linken wird es einen konsequenten
politikwechsel geben wird es ein schluss
mit der politik der verlorenen zeit der
letzten 16 jahre geben wir können so
nicht weiter unsere wirtschaftsweise
betreiben wir müssen sozial anders
denken wir müssen so ökologisch anders
handeln und dafür haben wir als linke
vorschläge gemacht wir wollten den
mindestlohn erhöhen wir wollten auch die
mieten decke wir wollen natürlich auch
eine soziale grundsicherung hartz wir
endlich endlich abschaffen das gibt es
ja immer noch und das ist natürlich ein
rückschlag erlitten das sind die
leidtragenden die bürgerinnen und bürger
in der